-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy-nominated actress
and comedian you know from shows
like "Schmigadoon!"
and "Saturday Night Live,
which airs this Saturday on NBC
with host Amy Schumer and
musical guest Steve Lacy.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Cecily Strong, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What a delight
to have you back, Cecily.
-Great to be back.
-Last time you were here,
we were talking about your place
in upstate New York.
And you referred to yourself
as a mountain woman
because of the wildlife
that you ran into up there.
-Yeah.
-I think, like, woodchucks.
Was that one?
-Mainly woodchucks.
-Yeah.
-That's why people get --
-Maybe there's wild turkeys.
-Oh, really?
-But it's woodchucks.
-But then you went to Canada
to film a second season
of "Schmigadoon!",
and this is not like --
This is not the middle
of the woods,
these photos you sent us.
-No.
-This seems
like pretty suburban.
-Yeah.
-And those are bears.
-Yes. So that's the house
we stayed in.
We didn't know there
would be bears like that.
They sort of told us
after we lived there.
And we were in Coquitlam.
-Okay.
-Which I think --
Then you Google it,
and it was, like,
"Bear Capital" or something.
And there's a lot of pictures
or videos of bears
reaching out for people,
walking trails,
or living in the suburbs.
-I guess when they told you
it was already based
on the photos a little bit,
it wasn't really breaking news
when they said
there's bears there.
-Right. It was --
-I mean, they were pretty close
to the old...
-Yeah, and that one's
got pizza or something.
It was every trash day.
And then also --
But the place we were staying
also had a koi pond.
And I was like, you know,
"I don't know much about bears,
but the one thing I do know
is they snatch fish
out of water."
-Yeah.
-So what are we doing
with the Old Country Buffet
in the backyard?
-Right.
It seems like a very --
like a place where fish
have no place to run.
It does not seem like
a very kind life for them.
You actually --
A friend of yours took a video
of one of the bears.
I guess this is --
From this vantage point.
-Yes. Right.
-Let's take a look at
to see one of these bears
in action.
-Bear, get away
from our trash can. Bear!
-Oh, thank God it's not
getting into ours.
-Now, does it, Cecily --
-Riveting commentary by Kevin.
-Does it hurt your feelings
when the bear just kind of
walks right past your trash?
-You know...no.
-Okay.
-No.
-This is the same place.
You took this photo
of this raccoon.
-That was Kevin, too.
Kevin would send me these photos
while I was shooting.
Like, a new wildlife thing
was happening.
This raccoon was sort of like,
"No, I'm trying -- The handle.
I'm trying to go in."
-This is the expression
of one being like,
"Can you give me a hand?"
-Yeah. He's about to be like,
"Yes. Right. The door.
I'm trying to go
into your kitchen."
-"I want to eat the garbage
from your kitchen."
-"Yeah, yeah, yeah."
-You did not take
this next photo.
But would you say this has been
a live-changing photo
that someone sent you?
-Yes.
-Before I show it to everybody,
tell me how you came about it.
-So, you know, news is tough
to stomach these days.
And sometimes I just --
I really appreciate when a story
shows up in my feed...
-Yeah.
-...that's like,
"Finally this is for me."
And it was the recent 2022
Comedy Wildlife Photos Awards.
And so, of course,
I had to look at all of them.
-Yes, and this is
an actual photo
that was taken in wildlife.
-This is an actual --
-I didn't take it,
but I love it.
-Tell us what...
-I mean...
-Now, this should --
That is in Florida.
-Okay.
-So, I mean,
that raccoon looks like --
I mean, it's like a neighbor.
Looks like he had
a late night.
And he's like, "Hey, y'all."
He's just, like, saying hi
while he's looking
for shrimp tails.
"Hey, y'all!" I don't know.
Just -- I really love him.
-So it puts you in a good mood.
When the news is bad,
you just kind of look at this.
You can pull this guy up
and feel better
how things are going.
-And I kind of want to, like --
You know, you have
your phone avatars or --
Is that what they're called?
-I think so.
-I'm very young and hip.
Your phone avatars.
-You mean, like,
your home screen of your phone?
-No, when your name comes up,
your contact.
I just want to change
all my photos to be him.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-I don't know if it's a he.
-Do you want me to change it
so if you ever call me
that's what I see?
-Yes. "Hey, Seth! Hey, dude!"
-It does feel like I'm going
to take out the trash,
and he's coming home
from a late night.
-He's the neighbor that --
-Yeah, he's on his way home,
and I caught him, like,
sneaking in.
-"Oh, hey, man." Yeah.
-You went snorkeling
in the Mediterranean.
-I did. Yes.
-Do you like that usually?
-No. Oh, wait. Which?
The Mediterranean or snorkeling?
Okay. Snorkeling is the one
I've never done.
I don't normally do
anything super --
anything at all active
or "dangerous."
-Snorkeling is, like,
barely active. Don't you think?
-But it's in an ocean.
-It is in an ocean.
I'll give you that.
Famously in an ocean.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. They say.
-Nobody snorkels in lakes.
I feel like that's not --
like a non-starter.
-Do they not?
-I feel like they don't.
Now I'm gonna hear
from our lake snorkelers,
but, yeah.
-Oh, God.
-That'll be a real can of worms.
-Yeah.
I want to read those letters.
No, we went --
we were touring the Calanque
in the Mediterranean.
-I feel like you're --
you made up a Canadian town.
-Oh. Coquitlam and Calanque.
-Yeah. I think
they're both made up.
-And I'm gonna do
one more hard "C."
-Okay.
-But I won't tell you when.
-So Calanque.
You were touring the Calanque.
What is the Calanque?
-The -- Oh, why would you
ever do this to me?
-You brought it up!
-That's as much
as I can tell you.
-You're touring the Calanque.
-I'm pronouncing it correctly.
That's as far as I'll get.
-Okay.
-They're, like,
rock-formation islands
in the Mediterranean.
-Well, I'm not gonna
follow-up Google.
That's enough for me.
-Please don't. No one do.
But -- So we did a boat tour,
and right away --
it was, like, this little guy
who smoked the whole time
and his name was Nico.
And he was like,
"But if you want to remember me,
you can just remember
my nickname is "Nicotine."
because there were --
there were so many Nicos.
-You met a bunch of Nicos
over your trip?
-Well, he said that his company
was a lot of Nicos.
I guess it's a popular
Marseilles boatsman,
sailor name.
But the first thing
he said to me,
which really threw me --
he was like,
"And you are the lady
I've just seen on my TV,
a Ghostbuster?"
And I was like,
"Huh. 'Ghostbusters.'"
I haven't gotten that one
in a while.
-Yes, Nico. I was in 2015's.
-That's really funny.
So you were -- You were
in "Ghostbusters" in 2015.
It's really funny
for someone to be like,
"I just saw it."
-Right.
And in another country,
on the ocean.
-You think they just --
-And that's someone you trust
to go snorkeling
for the first time.
-Yeah. Do you think movies just
get to Calanque a lot later?
-Uh, you know, sure. Sure.
I'm already in trouble
for not knowing enough.
-Yeah. We'll just move on.
You did. We mentioned her,
obviously, earlier tonight,
but you played Kari Lake.
This is kind of, like,
right up your alley.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-And, I mean, this is -
there's a certain kind of person
in the news that you have been
crushing on "SNL"
for a decade-plus.
When she shows up,
do you sort of --
Do you feel a gravitational pull
towards the...
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I, you know --
I kind of clock them
as they come.
And then I think the first thing
that happened
when I got to work
was Tucker said,
"We want you --
We want you to be her."
-This is Bryan Tucker,
the writer.
Bryan Tucker.
-Not Tucker Carlson,
the Fox News -- Okay.
-Yes.
-Tucker Carlson
works at "SNL" now.
-He text me sometimes
just with funny ideas,
and they are hilarious!
Carlson. That's my third "Cuh."
That's my third hard "C."
He's a -- Yeah.
The hard "C," Tucker.
No, Bryan Tucker, who is
different than Tucker Carlson.
And Will Stephen wrote this.
And it was -- Yeah.
This is my wheelhouse.
-Yeah.
-I just love someone who is --
you know, what's
simmering underneath.
-Yes, very calm, you know,
with like a -- Yeah, exactly.
The underpinning is very rocky.
Rocky seas.
-Oh, yes.
-Yeah.
-Similar to the Mediterranean.
That was a neat...
-That was really neat
what you just did.
Do you want to give us
any final words
about your buddy right here?
Like, if you were, like,
going on a road trip,
what would this guy say
as he saw you pulling out?
-I mean, that guy would,
number one, be like,
"Where you going?"
He doesn't know that
you're going on a road trip.
But he'd probably be like,
"Can I come?"
-Yeah.
-"Or can you grab me
a six-pack?"
He started saying that.
"You mind grabbing me
a six-pack on the way home?"
-Maybe he's not -- for a reason
we won't get into --
he's not allowed
to drive right now.
-Across state lines.
-He's not allowed to...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's got
a little raccoon ankle monitor.
He's out for a cigarette.
-Yeah. He's out for a cigarette.
He's always like --
And he's always got like --
He's working, like, a wrench
into the ankle monitor
trying to like...
-Yes.
You hear him yelling
about something on TV.
He's like,
"You see that storm last night?"
You're like,
"I don't know. I guess."
He always talks about storms.
-I like this dude.
Yeah, he's very into storms.
-Yeah.
-Hey, thank you so much
for sharing him with us.
I know -- I know
he means a lot to you.
Thanks so much for being here.
It's always a delight.
You guys, Cecily Strong.
"Saturday Night Live" airs
this Saturday on NBC
with host Amy Schumer
and musical guest Steve Lacy.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."